die zukunft von asia technologie auf ihn
und mobil sind sie eine völlig neue art
verbraucher
nur noch vision und fertig schnell
einfach intuitiv
mehr als ein drittel der 640 millionen
menschen von asian sind zwischen 15 und
34 wir sind eine der beliebtesten marken
bei jugendlichen um gelerntes perfekt
für eine der jüngsten bevölkerungen der
welt der wandel erschafft chancen
sind passieren schafft kann es überall
schaffen
freizeit lifestyle online-handel und
führung heute sind alle voller
leidenschaft und zuversicht mit know-how
aus aller welt
sie sind die nächste generation in asien
[Musik]
[Applaus]
willkommen in bangkok der hauptstadt
thailands der zweitgrößten
volkswirtschaft von asia bibi ganz
südostasien den höhenflug der online
wirtschaft nutzen will
die ganze regierung setzt dabei auf eine
neue jüngere verbraucher schicht
das durchschnittsalter liegt bei nur 29
jahren somit sind melanie lässt die
treibende kraft einer florierenden
mittelschicht der bis 2030 330 millionen
menschen angehören könnten mehr als das
doppelte verglichen mit 2009 10
in den letzten 30 jahren hat sich so
viel verändert
als ich hierherkam und zwar aus aber
kein wort sprach sich allerlei komische
blicke an
heute sind alle voller leidenschaft und
zuversicht mit know-how aus aller welt
die so genannten meeresschildkröten
kommen zurück sie waren im ausland
bringen das wissen und die leidenschaft
aus aller welt zurück in ihre heimat
technologie wird aktuelle entwicklungen
nur beschleunigen
alles wird schneller besser und
günstiger
in indonesien und ganz asien gibt es
viele junge und hart arbeitende menschen
die sehr vernetzt sind und probleme
lösen wollen
technologie wird ganz als ja nur helfen
es in asien zu etwas bringen kann
schafft es überall
umgekehrt nicht unbedingt
plötzlich müssen wir nicht mehr wie
früher traditionelle logistik und
telekommunikationsnetze aufbauen 5g
breitet sich zum beispiel sehr schnell
in der region aus
der digitale konsum ist gewaltig ohne
wie bisher üblich lange voll auf phasen
die nächsten zwei oder drei jahre werden
in südostasien die kritische phase sein
das wachstum in den kommenden 15 jahren
wird gewaltig sowohl in bezug auf konsum
als auch investitionen und die
entwicklung der ganzen region
kommen gerade viele länder ist zurück
führte sich im ausland ausbilden ließen
und andere länder kennen lernten
bei zeitgleich steigt das bildungsniveau
der arbeiterschaft in nie dagewesenem
maße
unsere generation ist besser ausgebildet
und viel reicher als alle fans
aus vater war der malaysische immobilien
und investment magnat laugung
mit zwei freunden mit ähnlichem
hintergrund wollte sie den größten
unabhängigen investmentfonds südost
asiens erschaffen
[Musik]
südostasien ist für uns der
interessanteste markt wird es wegen der
jungen bevölkerung auch noch zehn 15
jahre lang bleiben
die generationen wandel verändert die
politik der konsum ist gewaltig und es
gibt eine hochgebildete sehr mobile
population die zum teil auch von außen
nach südostasien einreist
wir sollten nicht außer acht lassen dass
es nicht nur um diejenigen geht die
bereits da sind sondern dass viele sogar
hierher kommen wollen
somit werden viele innovative ideen in
diesem teil der welt gelangen
asian hat in den letzten 60 jahren
gewaltige fortschritte gemacht handel
und wirtschaftsleistung sind um das 20
bis 30 fache gestiegen
technologie kann diese entwicklung noch
weiter beschleunigen denn sie macht
nicht nur die produktion schneller
besser und günstiger
sondern löst auch probleme schneller
in indonesien und ganz asien den können
viele probleme bei der infrastruktur im
zahlungsverkehr in bezug auf
arbeitskräfte und know how durch
technologie gelöst werden
es ist für uns in südostasien
unglaublich wichtig in talente zu
investieren wir haben gerade er ist
unsere zentrale in singapur eingeweiht
eine finte zentrale in malaysia
eingerichtet und bilden dadurch von
beginn an hunderte menschen aus
zusätzlich bringen wir experten aus
silicon valley und europa hier her um
den austausch zu fördern
mittelfristig wollen wir talente in der
gesamten region fördern
kann million ist ein unternehmer aus
asien im höhenflug und wurde durch die
ipo seiner firma razor milliardär
der gebürtige singapurer will seinem
unternehmen mit sitz im silicon valley
in südostasien zu einem neuen
wachstumsschub verhelfen wir sehen
südostasien als einen gewaltigen
wachstumsmarkt für uns wir unser
unternehmen
die sehr junge bevölkerung ist überaus
technologie affine und verlangt geradezu
nach konsum und entertainment
darin sehen wir bei razer eine gewaltige
chance sofern wir es schaffen passende
produkte für die bevölkerung der region
anzubieten
unsere digitale wirtschaft ist china
zehn jahre hinterher aber wir holen
schneller auf als alle vor uns china
die usa und europa brauchten viel länger
für den ausbau der digitalen wirtschaft
wir stehen noch am anfang aber bewegen
uns schon schneller als alle anderen
wirtschaftszonen zuvor hier einige
beispiele für die vernetzung südost
asiens die philippinen führen weltweit
bei der nutzung sozialer medien in asien
bei der handynutzung für den
online-handel und thailand beim internet
browsing über das handy
unsere internetnutzung ist hochgradig
mobil
wir sind viel mehr unterwegs als die
generation vor uns
technologie meiner meinung nach
schneller anpassungsfähiger und
intuitiver werden
anstatt fünf schritten brauchen ja nur
noch zwei wir wissen um sind fertig
einfach und intuitiv haben
ich bin 2011 als zweiter mitarbeiter von
la sala inditex branche eingestiegen
damals hatten wir 20 prozent der
menschen in thailand internetzugang
heute sind es 70 oder 80 prozent
der handybesitzer liegt wohl bei 110
prozent spricht jeder hat mindestens ein
handy
das gab es vor zehn jahren so einfach
nicht das musste sich erst entwickeln
heutzutage kann sogar mein mann aus
norwegen der in thailand lebt aber kein
wort teil spricht überall hinkommen
und ich rede nicht nur von taxis er kann
geschäfte machen mit anwälten reden
märkte erschließen es hat sich so viel
getan allein schon in bangkok
südostasiens online wirtschaft soll sich
durch die verbreitung des internets in
den nächsten fünf jahren mindestens
verdreifachen auf bis zu 250 milliarden
dollar
zwar verspricht die digitale wirtschaft
der jungen generation von asian
mannigfaltige chancen doch asien muss
den wandel noch vollziehen
sonst wird diese nächste generation zwar
alt aber nicht reich werden
das weltweite angebot im internet wächst
und der anteil vernetzter menschen ist
in manchen ländern sehr hoch während ein
großer teil von asian noch nicht mit
industrienationen mithalten kann wer in
indonesien das internet nutzen kann
macht regen gebrauch davon während über
30 prozent der bevölkerung noch gar
keinen zugang haben von gesundheit und
bildung ganz zu schweigen
droht indonesien alt zu werden bevor der
reichtum
das ist eine verbreitete ansicht wenn
wir nicht aufpassen könnte aus uns ein
land mit mittlerem einkommen werden
somit würden die vorhersagen indonesien
könnte in 20 oder 30 jahren platz fünf
gesetzen reine fantasie bleiben
genau daran will präsident djukow wie
arbeiten
wir müssen uns auf bedürfnisse
konzentrieren auf prozesses ebenso wie
die weiche infrastruktur
demographie ist der schlüssel zum erfolg
die demographie ist aber auch die
herausforderung wir müssen die richtige
bildung und die richtigen einstellungen
vermitteln
die barclay ist ceo von
in einer indonesischen investment firma
die in allen bereichen tätig ist vom
bergbau bis zur telekommunikation
damit die inklusion erfolg hat braucht
es gerechte bildung
wie soll das funktionieren
nach dem ausbau der hafeninfrastruktur
brücken helfen und straßen steht der
ausbau der reichen infrastrukturen
gesundheit und bildung
doch welche bildung ist am besten für
die industrialisierung 4.0 geeignet
wir müssen ja nicht nur gute schüler
ausbilden sondern brauchen auch ihm so
gute lehrerbildung
ich hatte gerade ein meeting zum thema
bildung für die massen
die millennials hier sind von dem thema
geradezu besessen
es geht nicht nur um work life balance
sondern um arbeit leben spiel und lernen
das lernen findet nicht länger von oben
herab stadt sondern auch anders herum
viele junge menschen sehnen sich nach
orten an denen sie etwas lernen aber
gleichzeitig auch spielen können
ich war heute erst bei drei bildung
startups sie warten nicht auf die
reformen des thailändischen
bildungsministeriums
den philippinen es ist quasi das gleiche
in ganz südostasien
sie gehen das ganze fernab alle
regulierungen rein pragmatisch
was braucht man wirklich um zu überleben
einen universitätsabschluss nicht jeder
wird dann mark zuckerberg solche genies
sind selten
man kann fähigkeiten erlernen um damit
sein geld zu verdienen
kevin war 2012 mitbegründerin eine
online handelsplattform für frauen jetzt
dreht sie die investmentfirma gobi
partners zu tech startups in südostasien
ich werde ständig nach dem nächsten
einhorn gefragt
dass thailand ist aber für den aufbau
einer firma hier überhaupt nicht
geeignet
deshalb ist uns alle nach sich zieht
dort winken investitionen von firmen und
initiativen wie temasek und spring davon
gibt es in thailand zu wenig
das erste teil einhorn wird also auch
eine firma mit sitz in singapur sein
wenn man heute von startups redet geht
es oft um das silicon valley oder
shenzhen in china
wird sich südostasien irgendwann auch zu
etablieren können
es geschieht bereits bei uns entstehen
bereits technologie einhörner
aber nicht so sehr wie in china
das wird sich voraussichtlich in den
nächsten jahren deutlich ändern
in diesem teil der welt entstehen
vielmehr tech startups
wir kommen aus dem silicon valley zurück
um nach interessanten firmen und start
ups zu suchen in die wir investieren
können
ich sehe hier in südostasien folglich
vor allem gewaltige chancen
das silicon valley bekommt aktuell
starke konkurrenz aus china seien kurz
willst du dass asien irgendwann auch bei
diesem rennen mitmischen
ich denke schon ich kenne ein paar leute
die ihre start-ups aus den usa nach
vietnam verlegen denn hier bekommen sie
fachkräfte für ein viertel der
arbeitskosten
kosten sind ein großer faktor und unser
markt hier ist sehr konkurrenzfähig mit
gut ausgebildeten fachkräften warum also
nicht
was steht im weg
die politik wir müssen einen besseren
politischen umgang mit der
bewegungsfreiheit ausländische
arbeitskräfte finden
der wirtschaft südost asiens ist noch
nicht gut genug integriert insbesondere
im vergleich mit europa sind wir wieder
in bezug auf fachkräfte mobilität noch
bei währungen konkurrenzfähig
unsere währungen fluktuieren stark und
willkürlich
die politik gibt die
entwicklungsbedingungen für ganz
südostasien vor
die ambitionen der jungen generationen
werden für die regierungen zunehmend
problematisch was sind die
herausforderungen
manche regierungen sehen sie als problem
andere als chance
die junge generation bezieht ihre
nachrichten und informationen nicht mehr
aus traditionellen quellen
sie gehen weniger ins kino lesen keine
zeitung und sehe nicht fern manche haben
auch keinen fernseher was tun sie denn
sie spielen videospiele
sie nutzen gerne virtuelle währungen und
beziehen informationen aus sozialen
medien
viele regierungen erlernen den umgang
mit ihnen gerade neu in
welchen bereichen haben die millennials
wie viel beigetragen
ich habe mich des öfteren darüber
unterhalten wie die neue regierung von
malaysia ihre wirtschaft regelt
ich bin der meinung dass sie ihre sache
besser machen als ihre vorgänger wobei
mir die meisten ökonomen widersprechen
würden
der grund ist ganz einfach wenn ich ein
bubble tierwelt muss ich zwei stunden
anstehen
im nagelstudio mich sogar fünf stunden
warten
was die wirtschaftsleistung angeht
konnten wir im diesjährigen bericht
sehen dass der private verbrauch in
malaysia ganz malaysia über den
erwartungen lag
das lieblich an infrastruktur oder
öffentlichen einrichtungen
es ist die privatwirtschaft es gibt
einfach einen nischenmarkt der
vernachlässigt wurde die ausgaben im
millennials für verbrauchsgüter
opnext gleich sehen wir uns an wie die
nächste generation von asian eine
einmalige chance für die zukunft
ergreift
[Musik]
die integration von asien läuft so gut
wie es geht wir müssen realistisch
bleiben
die zehn länder sind wirtschaftlich
verschieden weit entwickelt es ist
schwierig sie als einheit mit
identischen riegeln und zellen zu
betrachten das geht einfach nicht
sie haben wird eine große region sein
das wachstum die stabilität die
demografische entwicklung all diese
faktoren tragen zum wachstum in der
region bei
die region ist auch wirtschaftlich
vielfältig thailand hat seinen stärken
ebenso malaysia singapur vietnam
indonesien die philippinen laos
kambodscha und myanmar diese region
steht großes bevor
die junge generation kambodschas hat
viel energie und sehnt sich nach bildung
[Musik]
um den wandel hin zur digitalisierten
industrie und wie die regierung sagt
elektronischen wirtschaft zu vollziehen
brauchen wir fähigkeiten und kompetenz
darum müssen wir unser bildungssystem
reformieren um die industrie in
kambodscha innovativ zu gestalten
es besteht immer das risiko manche axel
hängen wenn wir aber gemeinsame ziele
setzen können wir ein inklusives
wachstum für alle erreichen
wir sollten nicht vergessen wenn die
flut kommt hebt sie alle boote
gleichermaßen darum müssen wir einander
helfen
niemand weiß wie asian in 10 20 oder 50
jahren aussehen wird ein solides
fundament schafft jedoch eine gute
perspektive
nun ist es an der staatsführung den
nächsten schritt zu wagen
das spiegeln die aktuelle führung südost
asiens die ambitionen der nächsten
generation wieder
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die politiker sind nach wie vor
durchschnittlich 70 jahre alt die bürger
im schnitt 29
ich bewundere ihre leistungen der
vergangenheit von ganzem herzen
aber es gibt viele probleme die sie
nichts angehen
zb
jeder sieht gerechtigkeit und bildung
anders
ich habe der regierung in malaysia schon
öfter gesagt sie sollen in die
technologie branche investieren im
westen mehr arbeitsplätze zu schaffen
als sie sich vorstellen können
des nokian fortschritt von asien besteht
kein zweifel
das durchschnittliche
wirtschaftswachstum aller zehn ländern
gibt seit zehn jahren jedes jahr bei
fünf prozent
die verbraucher schicht wächst es gibt
bessere löhne mehr arbeitsplätze und
mehr infrastruktur
auch der online handel ist trotz
bescheidene anfänge im höhenflug
meine vision für südostasien ist recht
bodenständig
großartige infrastruktur und software
großartige regularien und politische
systeme
station korruption und bestechung
vollkommen aus und richten bessere
staatsführung mit mehr rechenschaft für
menschen und alle beteiligten ein
und wir lösen uns vom politischen
ränkespielen und persönlicher ideologie
wird asien in 10 20 jahren aussehen
wird sehr viel selbstbewusster sein die
zahlen werden uns bestätigen in zehn
zwanzig jahren wird die wirtschaft von
asian 13 millionen us dollar erreichen
das entspricht der wirtschaftsleistung
von großbritannien frankreich und
deutschland zusammen
mit derartiger größe kommt das
selbstvertrauen wir hoffen dass
indonesien das heute 40 prozent davon
aus macht entsprechend mitwachsen kann
in den nächsten 10 15 jahren werden wir
sehen wie die jugend sich auch über die
grenzen südost asiens hinweg durchsetzen
wird und die sich hier vielmehr start up
zu etablieren werden ihr traum für asian
in zehn jahren
ein geeinter markt wäre großartig asien
muss sich selbst als gewaltigen markt
erkennen einigkeit ist immer wichtig und
ich würde gerne einen geeinten markt
entstehen sie
ich hätte gerne eine vielzahl an firmen
die sich durch ganz asien bewegen und
asien nicht nur als geeinten markt die
sondern auch als geeinte bevölkerung
sehen
bei inklusion nachhaltigkeit und
vernetzung könnte sich der endspurt
jedoch als die größte herausforderung
erweisen
wenn es darum geht unsere größten
gemeinsamen probleme zu lösen sind alle
leidenschaftlich dabei
die sanitärversorgung die ausweitung des
einzelhandels in bestimmten regionen
die einrichtung von fantec damit das
finanzwesen günstiger wird und darlehen
pünktlich bezahlt werden können
wir alle müssen die gleichen hindernisse
überwinden und die gleichen probleme
lösen
in sachen identität sind wir alle erfolg
haben aber auch unsere eigenheiten
[Musik]
es geht um uns und unser erbe bis zum
unsere eltern oder großeltern zu
viele haben kein bankkonto der aktuelle
finanzmarkt lässt zu viele probleme
ungelöst
hier können wir das aus der perspektive
der jüngeren bewohnern südostasiens
lösen
das durchschnittsalter in südostasien
ist 29 jahre
wir sind südostasien nicht die über 60
jährigen politiker
wir sind die kommende generation
[Musik]
zukunft asiens ist hier und sie ruht auf
den schultern einer jungen generation
der sich dank schneller veränderung eine
einmalige chance bietet
danke für ihre aufmerksamkeit bei asian
the next generation
[Musik]